ich komme aus dem letzten restaurant
dass wir heute getestet haben drei
neueröffnungen und ich sage euch so viel
es lohnt sich das video zu schauen wir
wurden komplett überrascht und ich würde
sagen wir starten mit dem frühstück es
gibt einen salat und zwar auf nacken
deshalb ab gehts es war sehr cool und
bleibt bis zum ende dran nicht was ich
zu unserem ersten spot statt salat das
ist mit der grund dafür dass dieses
video überhaupt drehe die haben mich
nämlich eingeladen volle transparenz
meinen eltern vorbei ist mal was und wir
testen das ganze nacht wie es gibt
bestimmt noch mehr neueröffnung und es
liegt erstmal sehr krass aus
[Musik]
gehört schon was dazu finde ich dass
mich so ein salat so richtig kann ich
das nehmen sie zu wissen wie so ein weg
ist ordert sich auf mexiko
man merkt dabei auch blockierer laden
neu ist oder jahre alter mann merkt es
komplett das ist ja jetzt brandneu der
brandneue man hat ja auch gemacht
seit gestern ist ich ehrlich so leute
okay ich sag mal so wenn man eingeladen
wird dann gönnt man sich auch was haben
wir noch so bauer bauholz dazu beginnt
und wasser sieht hübsch aus ist übelste
werden wir das wahrscheinlich das was
aufs wasser zu treffen aber
schmeckt sehr gut man muss auch wirklich
sagen in der laden zieht auch die leute
hier so in der großstadt wird zweiter
tag offen und polen
[Musik]
wir packen ein bisschen limette noch
über das ist wirklich in letzter zeit so
mein favourit zum mexikanische einflüsse
zum frühstück das sieht das nicht so
schön aus 392 glaube dies krass alter 7
10 99 das ist in so ländlicheren
restaurants einfach so von mir
oder zu dir sehr schön mit 1 euro werden
für einen oberkochen tag dafür kommen 18
tage kocht wo wir man jetzt mit der
polin mexican source
ein paar monate zeit dann so ein
bisschen geröstete süßkartoffeln cherry
tomate
deshalb hat er wirklich sehr sehr lecker
was spur könne
so authentisch ist also eine chemie
mathe note noch mal braucht damit sie
diese kabel an banker schwarze bohnacker
mode geröstetes cherry tomaten rucola
und reißt und es schmeckt und sehr sehr
gut wo wir sie auch die teuerste ball
von 17 eur 90
bio rind dabei also große wii-fans schön
rosa muss man sagen wir sind brokkoli
noch dazu oder blumenkohl
was erwartet man halt auch nicht allen
voran schmeckt es einfach super fresh
und wenn man sieht wie hinter mir ist
einfach so ein supermarkt so eine
gemüseabteilung frische abteilung quasi
aufbauen so dass ihr das leben kann so
schmeckt auch so ein thema das schon so
aufbaut dann weiß man auch dass man
nichts zu verstecken hat man auch mit
dinge quatschen sie meinen sie sind nur
zu 20 prozent restaurant dich hinsetzt
weil sonst liefert ein ich würde sagen
dass uns das jetzt einmal wirken lassen
und dann packen wir nochmal oder
schleunigst neueröffnung bei sowas ist
einfach weil du wirst du immer
überrascht findet so was
schon mal in hamburg oder berlin
fazit von uns allen dreien wir haben
alle gesagt jetzt nicht gedacht dass so
gut ist und ich war auch reggae zu sagen
obwohl die mich eingeladen haben dass es
nicht so gut ist aber es ist einfach
sehr krass also essen sehr frischer
salat geile dressings neiße zutaten und
ich kann es nur empfehlen also erste
neueröffnung ist auf jeden fall bin ich
bin gespannt was die zweite bringt der
spot ja eine sache die wahrscheinlich
viele von euch schon gesehen haben
selbst wenn sie nicht aus köln kommen
haus des döners und diesem laden gibt es
erst seit zwei wochen und man findet ihn
nicht mal bei google ist noch der
vorherige laden da das haben wir gerade
erst ein bisschen gesucht aber wir sind
endlich da ich heute sagen wir gehen
rein
[Musik]
das ist also ich schwöre leute das ist
wirklich nicht übertrieben das macht
gerade was mit mir dieser knoblauchsoße
tätig ist auch mal recht mal fühlst du
es gibt dir das was er für mich ist das
wirklich der geruch und meinem kind
heizt er ich weiß noch ganz genau das
ist glaube ich wirklich so gewesen 1
euro 50 habe ich auf dem nachhauseweg
immer bezahlt aus der grundschule
wirklich 1 euro 50 personen halben
schüler döner und zwar eine ganz ganz
schwere zeit jetzt hier dieser bilder
der wahl auch wirklich in nullkommanix
fertig sind zwar keine minute also
ich glaube ich glaube ich habe einen
döner in köln von höchst immer so ich
war immer so ja kann man nicht sogar
döner essen und so diese samen brot
durch diese knoblauchsoße für mich was
ein döner zu einem geilen döner macht
bewusst nicht so überladen
man lernt ja geschmack du bist was immer
und immer wieder und dann erst okay dass
ein dünner für mich und das ist so nah
an dem was ich immer meine heimat
gegessen habe
es war hier so einen schönen gruß
hinblick auf ältere
wagen
komplett
aber für mich hat es natürlich nicht
diese nostalgie gefühl der macht
trotzdem normal für richtig indem er
einfach auch so schön so fluffig
trotzdem vorher so du hast nicht so
etwas schweres in der hand wenn nur ein
beißt er ist ja schon was breit aber nur
einmal es geht trotzdem so schön
zusammen das wird ein richtig luft sich
trotzdem ein super butter döner und auch
wenn ich probiere so diesem nostalgie
effekt auszublenden bei sich des krieges
auch an genießen ihr habt ja gesehen
also ich hab ja bei vergessen also das
ist was ganz anderes und das habe ich
auch bei fährt schon gesagt so der fährt
müller der beste dünger oder der westen
seine eigenen kategorien seiner eigenen
liga hat seine eigene zubereitung aber
in der welt der normalen döner ist das
hier wird champions-league-tor mir
persönlich gibt auch nichts dass du so
oft auf das game spielt und so nein aber
wenn der dünner stimme ist doch egal
genauer sich rage nur den döner und ich
wusste dass sie diese sauce geben würde
aber ich wusste nicht dass sie so sehr
für mich so home bietet so eine
graduelle auch hier das ist jetzt neu
eröffnung der standort ist läuft aber
den laden gibt es auch häufig sondern
also wir haben ein laden heute im video
der wirklich brandneues wenn es nur
einmal auf der welt gibt dem gehen wir
jetzt das hier absolut drin für mich
freue mich auf ein besonderes abendessen
und ihr werdet gleich sehen warum ich
hab's euch gesagt das ist etwas ganz
besonderes der laden hinter mir das puls
ist ganz neu in köln und das ist das
restaurant von daniel gottschlich also
von dem koch aus dem ochsen klee
erinnert euch vielleicht das teuerste
restaurant in köln in dem wir waren und
ich habe ein bisschen kontakt mit dem
daher gehalten so auch mitbekommen dass
jetzt neue lage entstanden ist gucken
wir uns an das ganze ist nicht
sterneküche sondern gute küche bisschen
einfacher gehalten also nicht nur menüs
sondern á la carte auch hab ich bock auf
sonntag schon wieder was geht ernst
gespannt weil es ist ja eigentlich eine
stärke sie haben einfach kein stern
ein bürger einmal eine große passt da
ein großes köpfchen alkohol einfach
[Musik]
wir sind einmal durch den laden
marschiert und wirklich sehr beschaulich
nicht riesengroß die plätze waren es 33
30 plätze drinnen außen noch mal acht
auf der terrasse diesem hintergrund
dürfen im wunderschönen goldene fassade
auch die karte sehr edel gehalten und
das interessante ist das ist quasi so
ein tab / r concept also man bestellt
sich ein paar speisen für die mitte für
den tisch man kann alle speisen entweder
als single oder als to share bestellen
dann kann jeder mal hier und da
probieren weit ich freue mich sehr
darauf dass ich glaube ich ein
gelungener abschluss oder so ein
anstrengender arbeitstag man das brot
sieht schon jetzt fahren halt einfach so
ist dude krank ist aber da wird auch
nicht mit öl gespart beim an rissen aber
es ist sehr sehr krank drauf und
[Musik]
brodkorb und dann so eine fallhöhe und
mit dem was da abgeht chili sein so dass
auf jeden fall mehr als einfach nur ein
brotkorb so und dass das führte zu beton
der örtlich lässt noch mal grüßen auch
schön das sind jetzt hier unsere bars
next oder starter und vanessa geguckt
dass ihren kleinen gruß man was ihr
licht gestellt habe damit einmal die
gebackenen argentinien ist das
eigentliche talente klassiker oder
risotto reis mädchen gebacken werden
dass ein bisschen modernisiert
aufgekommen mit einer wiimote füllung
ist ein käse ein bisschen scharf
abgeschmeckt und geröstete pistazien
creme und eingelegte salz orange wie es
dann weiter auf dem knochen serviert
katar vom deutschen 3 extras aus
menschenknochen
genau das ganze dann auf kopfsalat mit
einer cherry mario eingelegt eigentlich
so zum snacken und man wird direkt
wieder so man wird so in andere welt
geschehen ist ist auch ich habe presse
was mein erster gedanke war so gut wie
alles war heute das hat jetzt wieder das
kein verein auszeit wieder kurs ist auch
eine ganz andere liga
es ist schon mal sehr hübsches finger
vielen anderen bars krieg so salzstangen
nie
wieder krieg so lackierten
also so lecker dieses rauchige so die
textur der crunch direkt mal so viel
spaß
kommen sie von der seinen fahrern und
dann hat man also dass zu so einem bier
oben und unten entschieden
[Musik]
so
erwärmt dein herz gut durch das an katar
romana salat herz mehr seitz ramzan
disco
wir sterben einfach heute so vor glück
jakob du hast ja so noch nicht so oft
gegessen
ich habe auf jeden fall noch nie das ist
keine lösung harrt noch nie gegessen
dann kommen wir sofort prügel diesem mix
von
so würde ich jeden tag essen ich will so
ein mal die woche essen
note weiß was hier machen würde hier
würde ich so somit so eine handvoll
guten freund mein geburtstag feiert
wir müssen gehen ist es zu lecker dass
die bürger hier so die tomaten auf dem
burger sind einfach gehäutet so wie viel
der location kann zu haben für das
produkt
was passiert auf der zunge
man soll als ihr schäfer gemeinsam
zusammen kommt und hier gemeinsam
genießen
wie das aussieht muss man durch die
kamera gucken bei unfassbar lecker oder
willst die sonne spielt aber auch so in
die karten dass jetzt so heftig aus
gebackener blumenkohl kennt man ja also
das glaube ich eine israelische küche
verbreitet aber man sieht auch schon
wieder hier ist dieses andere geleistet
hat überall so schöne knusprige ecken
wir haben da oben drauf magie viele
bunte blumen granatäpfel ich bin sehr
gespannt wie es schmecken wird wir haben
hier knochen freie bahn lässt die beere
korrigieren dazu haben wir topinambur
kommen bietet jetzt erst probleme
es ist schon nicht verkehrt also not
wofür ist das statement dabei gucken wo
ist das verstehst nicht dass sie zu
schön hart und wird es nicht essen ich
würde sagen ich werde in meinem regal
stellen so wie ich das verstanden ist
das komplett veganer
ich habe keinen grund zu lachen weil es
zu krass ist das ist so das kommt so und
historiker es ist dunkel das wollte ich
auch sagen weil es in den blumenkohl
rein und weiß zeitgleich in die ganze
welt in die
sonne gehen wir wenn es leicht und wir
wollten uns eigentlich kurz fassen auch
zu dem gericht ja aber es geht nicht es
passiert ganz grosse klasse unter den
allerbesten restaurants not ja auch
katja und so ein ressourcen wir waren
dass es unter den top 3 unter anderem
entspannten tag ist es teuer aber es ist
nicht so toll hersteller ist das hat
mich ein bisschen sprachlos gemacht weil
es so krass war zwar alles so heftig und
ich habe mit viel gerechnet aber nicht
mit dem hier also ich habe jetzt schon
wirklich viel gutes gesagt und ich meine
alles 100 prozent ernst deshalb absolute
empfehlung wirklich nichtsdestotrotz
auch die anderen beiden spox waren ja
auch auf ihre art und weise wirklich
richtigkeit gegessen wie ein kaiser
wieder älter ist unglaublich also danke
dass ihr die videos schaut dass mir das
ermöglicht so weit in diesem sinne leute
dank fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal